when I took the GMAT to get into Harvard
I read this study on how to do well on
standardized tests and they had this
graph and it went like this the more
problems you did on average the higher
your test score was so I bought 16 phone
books like they're like these thick like
test prep books and I did four hours of
problems every day for three months and
then I scored a 99 Point whatever
percentile because it was just input
output I was naturally not even that
good at math but I just was like if I do
ten thousand [__] problems like I'll
start to just understand how these
problems get asked for me that's what
gives me the confidence to say like what
if it's not working like it will
eventually if we just keep doing it it
will work